Quality Options, Quality, Quality, Quality Options, Quality, Quality Options, Options,
Options, Quality Options, Nice, Quality Options am Start, yeah, das ist massiv, oh, warum zeigt
er nichts an, ah, weil die, weil die noch minimiert sind, ja, da, da ist er, proggers,
ich hab, ich hab, also wir haben halt ungefähr nur zwei Stunden Zeit, richtig proggers, es
müsste mir irgendjemand, wer sowas gut kann, müsste mir unbedingt mal ein proggers Pepe
machen, nur mal so zur, zur Erklärung was wir heute vorhaben, ne, ihr seht ja wie lang
das hier, ah, ich warte mal, Kirby, Kirby, muss mal kurz, bisschen, bisschen leiser machen,
komm mal, wir machen wieder unseren 24-7-Chillzoo an, ok, warum auch immer sich die Stream-Ult
von denen langsam laufend ändert, ich weiß es nicht, oh, was jetzt, hallo, YouTube,
sag mal, ist ernsthaft, ist ernsthaft Anklicken, ist ernsthaft Anklicken von YouTube Sachen
gerade kaputt, jetzt, jetzt gehts, ok, nein, FireFox hat rumgespackt, ne, ich bin übrigens
jetzt auch nicht lauter als sonst, achso, das auch war der, ja, lull, machen wir mal
so, dann ist es recht angenehm von der Lautstärke her, ne, so, ich bin auch nicht lauter, ich
hab einfach so sehr ins Mikro vorgeschrien eben, so, noch kurz wieder post, sag mal,
ich hab grad gesehen auf dem Handy, dass das Doktor Haus im Chat ist, ich bräuchte eine
kurze Diagnose, ähm...
ja und zwar die frage die ich habe bist du zufällig derjenige der mir die max
fps domain verschachert hat im wahrsten sinne des wortes
habe ich das overlay aus? ich habe das overlay aus
aber du warst der der die kommande kriege homepage gemacht hat
dann bringe ich was durcheinander du heißt nicht eddie oder so
wobei das hätte ich eigentlich in den e-mails sehen müssen
doch dann hast du mir die max fd
oder bringe ich das jetzt komplett durcheinander
also die die sache ist nämlich die
irgendein typ hat mir damals max fps de weggecrabt und war dann der meinung er
könnte mir anbieten das ganze zu verkaufen
und irgendwie habe ich im hinterkopf das warst du
ja gut wenn du sagst du warst nicht dann kann ich jetzt auch nichts dagegen sagen
so also mal zur erklärung was wir heute vor haben wir müssen uns ein bisschen
beeilen weil das wird grausam werden ich weiß es jetzt schon
du hast mir meine website eingebunden
nee ok dann machst du das nicht ich weiß ich weiß nicht mal wer das gewesen ist
dann bringe ich das durcheinander es hat mal irgendwann einer hat sich halt die
hat sich die max fps domain weg mir quasi weggeschnappt und wollte dann
ordentlich asche dafür haben wir haben uns dann im endeffekt auf irgendwie
relativ geringen betrag geeinigt da ging das auch ja aber ja war ich schon ein
bisschen stinkig kann man daran erinnern aber auch schon wieder jahre her als
ewig her also also mal zur erklärung was wir heute machen wollen ist jetzt alles
ok sowohl von quality options meiner lautstärke musiklautstärke und so kann
man kann man das so lassen
so und zwar was wir heute machen wollen nur so dass man das man es checkt also
wir haben ein paar probleme das erste problem ist die domain gehört mir jetzt
jaja also das ist ja so wir haben wir haben paar
bugs also wir haben einmal diesen bug hier ich zeige es euch noch mal ihr seht
dass die bilder also unabhängig davon dass dieses komische rekt tangle da
unten ist das war weg machen das backen auch ein bisschen rum
ihr seht wenn ich die bilder umschalte dann legen die noch kurz nach beim
position wechseln das liegt an den liegt daran wie wpf das ganze render da
habe ich relativ wenig einfluss drauf also wir könnten bestimmt irgendwie
irgendwelche krassen wpf hex abziehen oder so aber da habe ich erstens keine
ahnung von außerdem glaube ich wird es schwierig und ziemlich eklig
ne seht ihr das also das letzte mal habt ihr es gesehen ich hoffe ihr seht es
heute immer noch wobei ich gebe zu sich schwierig weil wir wissen ja alles
menschliche augen sieben plus fünf fps aber das sollte man trotzdem mal zwei
versteht sich aber das sollte man trotzdem sehen dass das nachleckt
soll das ist das erste problem was wir haben und das zweite problem ist
guck mal da sind baro ist auch da und das zweite problem ist dass
gifs die ein bisschen größer sind also 0 3d ist klein das das geht schnell ja
aber gibt es die ein bisschen größer sind ich meine es nicht die anzeige
größe sondern halt halt datei größe und und auflösung dass die ewig brauchen
zum anzeigen der hier geht da ist auch relativ klein man sieht ja auch die
qualität nicht schlecht aber zum beispiel hier der mein blown typ wo ist
er da guck mal wie lange das dauert ich ich hau ich heme jetzt mal auf die maus
dass ihr es hört so das dauert naja was meint ihr wie lange das ungefähr ist
ich würde mal sagen eine sekunde so in dem dreh ja und ach ja es ist eine
sekunde und wie guckt euch mal die die war ich muss noch mal neustern und
guckt euch mal die ram auslastung an passt mal auf
hast mal auf seite wieder herstellen ist ich guck mal ram auslastung aktuell ist
ja alles noch ok na und wenn man gifs anzahle das sind auch die dinger die
noch keine feste größe haben ja na und wenn man das bleibt auch so
ungefähr auf dem dreh das piekt mal kurz und dann ist gut vor allem beim
resizing spackt das rum also sie das braucht kaum ram im endeffekt was ist
denn das hier jetzt irgendwie 170 oder so ja 170 ram und jetzt passt mal auf wenn
ich einen gif lade was klein ist ist auch kein ding
na passt schon aber wenn ich den gif lade was groß ist guckt euch das mal an in
your face wenn ich das schnell hintereinander mache dann geht es
teilweise bis zum gigabyte hoch und das ist halt übelst fail und das liegt
daran verheitens 174 mb schon hat das geht eigentlich ich meine das ist im
prinzip dass das ganze das komplette sp dort net core gedöns im hintergrund mit
mit mvc und hast du nicht gesehen alles geladen und die wpf anwendung das ist
schon in ordnung ich meine da da irgendwelche ultra light weight c++
dinger macht so ist es bestimmt kleiner aber das ist insgesamt ist da schon ok
aber zumindest ist halt die das gif islam das gift program und es sagt so und
deswegen machen wir heute ja das ist relativ groß also guck mal da also wenn
ich es einfach nur starte ohne dass ich es was machen das ist die hier beim
starten sobald alles da ist und die ersten die quests gelaufen sind haben
ungefähr 170 mb oder 100 ja 150 mb aber ungefähr 150 mb da ist ein bisschen
zeug noch sein datenbank ausgelesen aber das ist ja im prinzip nur text und auch
nicht sonderlich viel also das geht nicht viel kleiner an der stelle also
quasi ich weiß nicht ob man kann man das irgendwo aufgeschlüsselt sich
anzeigen was was braucht ich habe keine ahnung ich benutze das so selten
vielleicht sieht man das irgendwie ein bisschen im task manager oder so wo ist
es überhaupt
web da ist es da meint er übrigens dass ich gebe auch mal weiß nicht was da da
alles mist also hier ist nur der meinung hat 72 mb und da ist auch irgendwie das
wpf zeug mit drinne und so das ist aber ok 180 mb für so ein komplettes den da
kann ich mit leben mir geht es auch gar nicht so sehr um den ramm verbrauchen
geht hauptsächlich darum dass der scheiß übelst lahm ist ich meine habt
ihr gesehen habt ihr gesehen wie gesagt die sekunde oder so in dem dreh ja den
du zum beispiel das ist halt übelst lahm und auch wenn wir mit dem windows oktober
update demnächst vielleicht uwp controls laden können die auch bessere gifs
anzeigen können und sonst was in der richtung es wäre natürlich schöner wenn
wir das selbst machen und es schneller ist und da können wir bei der
gelegenheit auch nicht nur gifs anzeigen einfach die ganzen anderen bilder auch
vielleicht wpf werden wir noch brauchen vielleicht brauchen wir auch gar kein
wpf man muss gucken und es ist halt viel viel schneller gestartet weil das ist
wirklich nervig man drückt jetzt hier drauf will ein bild anzeigen dann ist
der gag quasi schon wieder rum wenn das eins bis zwei sekunden später kommt und
das ist jetzt ja immer noch ein relativ kurzes gif wenn da einen gif quasi mit
den fps in der datei größe und der auflösung macht was mal 20 sekunden
lang ist dann ist wahrscheinlich mein ramp voll oder so also die diese komische wpf gif
library ist nicht so der hit deswegen probieren wir das ganze mal selbst zu
machen und zwar dazu brauchen wir also ich habe mir das im vorfeld schon ein
bisschen überlegt wie wir das machen können dazu brauchen wir ffm pack dazu
brauchen wir teile von frisi lull kennt ihr frisi lull noch frisi lull das ist
mal das screenshot tool was wir angefangen haben für black desert
da sind nämlich ein paar direkt x teile drin die können wir zum render nehmen
brauche frisi lull ja guck brauche ich brauche ein paar teile von frisi lull weil ich
ich weiß aus dem kopf vom besten will nicht mehr wie man wie man direkt x
devices erstellt und geschiss da alle keine ahnung deswegen das kopiere ich
mir einfach aus frisi lull also das heißt wir brauchen ffm pack direkt x
beziehungsweise direkt 2d und wir brauchen einiges an unsafe code deswegen
werde ich jetzt mal zum testen einfach eine ganz normale windows form app
machen ohne irgendwas ich mache mal ein neues visual studio auf das meme tool
lassen wir mittag und laufen nicht genutzt der memory ist verschenkter
memory im prinzip schon ja ist das ist ja auch so wenn man sich mal überlegt
was bringt es mir dass ich irgendwas habe ich 16 g oder so sieht man das
überhaupt hier dass ich 16 g habe und davon im prinzip fast nie mehr als 8
belegt ist was was was habe ich davon im endeffekt so wir machen jetzt mal um
das zu testen eine ganz normale billige windows forms app wo wir überhaupt
nichts mit windows forms machen sondern direkt mit direkt x reinballern und
gucken ob wir irgendwie da gifs rein gerendert kriegen wie gesagt ich habe
schon ein bisschen ffm pack zeug am start aus anderen sachen die ich gemacht
habe und da und ich zeug kopieren wir uns aus frisi lull
übrigens wahrscheinlich gucken heute nicht so viele zu weil alle battlefield
kommen vermute ich mal
so aber immer billige billige windows forms geschichte an
der frau pelfin ich habe mir ich habe es mir noch gar nicht geholt na ich will
auch immer überlegen ob ich mir wirklich die wirklich preorder und und zeugs
alles hole wahrscheinlich nicht
oder zu wöchentlichen morgen vielleicht ich meine das game soll ja eigentlich
erst morgen auskommen sie schon am spielen weiß auch nicht was das warum und
wie und was auch immer ist auch vollkommen wurscht so gut also von der
idee her machen wir jetzt folgendes
wir kopieren uns jetzt mal von frisi lull das anlegen von direkt x devices
weil das weiß ich aus dem kopf nicht mehr also das erste was wir machen ist
wir stellen alles was wenn du aus forms macht ab das heißt was da am ende
rauskommt ist ein fenster was absolut nichts tut nicht nicht refreshed und
einfach gar nichts macht so weil das wollen wir alles selber mal das heißt
wenn aus forms eigentlich plus für ein bisschen resize und gedönste events
drumherum da mehr brauchen wir nicht und wir machen sie auch später nicht in
windows form sondern entweder bauen wir das in wpf ein oder wir brauchen weder
noch und machen einfach ein nackisches fenster auf mit direkt x drin dafür die
bilder weil im prinzip macht man frontend her eh nichts außer bilder am
zeigen und wenn ich die bilder selbst rennen kann brauche ich den ganzen
egui framework gab es da nicht mehr drumherum also wir schalten mal alles aus
was das was das ganze macht und legen jetzt mal das kopieren wir uns aus
frisi lull raus
wir machen jetzt ein schwarz also wir brauchen auch ein fps counter wir brauchen
auch ein fps counter das heißt ich ich werde jetzt mal den den schlechtesten
fps counter zusammen hacken der mir so einfällt der ist wahrscheinlich also
erst mal muss ich erst mal muss ich direkt x und zeugs installieren überhaupt sie
scharpe grämpel dazu nehmen wir scharpe dx
warum bist du nicht auf dem schlachtfeld ich hab gar kein bock scharpe dx brauchen wir
using übrigens noch für alle die nicht die nicht oft die nicht oft studio
verwenden ihr könnt wenn ihr auf was seid was ihr noch importieren müsst
könnt ihr einfach alt ich glaube altpunkt und steuerung punkten in dem
fall geht nur steuerung punkt weil visual studio korte ist glaube ich altpunkt
steuerung punkt drücken und dann so zwischen studio was quasi am nächsten
passt das brauchen wir nämlich auch noch und ich kann mir einfach abgucken was
ich was ich brauche aus frisi lull ich brauche scharpe dx direkt 2d brauche ich
dann sind wir richtig modern und im x11 ich meine wir machen im endeffekt
nichts außer ein bild malen aber das kann man auch mit 11 mal machen weil wir
sind halt modern dann brauchen wir auch direkt direkt die microsoft benahmung
das war mal so eine zeit wo microsoft alles direkt genannt hat und danach
haben sie alles 1 irgendwas genannt wenn das ist glaube ich schon drinne kann das
sein die xgi brauche ich noch
das brauchen wir noch aber ist schon installiert ok nice dann war es eigentlich
mal brauche ich glaube ich nicht
wir müssen noch sagen welches device wir als device wollen weil natürlich die
ganzen sachen in den microsoft namespaces gleich heißen
so using using using using gut so und jetzt machen wir einfach einen schwarzen
hintergrund mit dx das ist alles mehr machen wir nicht ich kopiere mir noch
mal kurz hier dieses set up resources aus dem frisi lull auch ganz praktisch
habe ich schon habe ich schon kopiert bescheuern
dann kopieren wir auch noch klinik resources
klinik hier weil wir müssen zwischendurch wenn das fenster re size auch
das ganze da ich soll ich re seisen so und dann brauchen wir noch create create
device so siehst du dafür ist schon mal gut dass wir an frisi lull rum
gebastelt haben so und dann sagen wir das create create device gefolgt von
disk reate
ich so warte wie habe ich den camp set up resources was habe ich damit
gedacht man ist bescheuert warum heißt das anders
mal gucken ob es jetzt geht und nicht kaputt geht anscheinend anscheinend
anscheinend ist es noch nicht gecrashed wer sich übrigens fragt wie man
windows forms und so weiter eine debug konsole fenster anzeigen kann einfach in
die settings gehen das ding auf konsole application umstellen es bleibt nach
wie vor eine windows form application überhaupt kein unterschied übrigens ich
sehe ganz viel ganz viel chat messages ich habe gerade nicht den überblick
was gforce experience mac oder windows notebook zum programmieren also wenn
wenn es also kommt drauf an was du programmieren willst was willst du
programmieren also wenn du wenn du dort nicht programmieren willst im studio
verwenden willst das war auch für meck gibt aber was komplett anderes ist dann
würde ich sagen eindeutig windows ansonsten ansonsten finde ich ist eine
super kombination wenn man einfach wenn man einfach nur was braucht was
ordentlich funktioniert und man halt ist nicht gerade unbedingt windows gui zeug
machen will ist ein linux notebook finde ich fast das beste
also zumindest trifft das mein geschmack am ehesten und ansonsten würde ich mich
da natürlich auch eher für meck entscheiden als für windows allerdings
was auch nicht schlecht ist was man kombination auch nicht unterschätzen
sollte ist wenn man windows zeug machen will ist windows mit einer mit
feinbar workstation und eine ordentliche linux vm das ist auch nicht verkehrt wie
oft in systemen die man sich mit dem pc oder dem pc oder dem pc oder dem pc
wie oft installierst du dann windows neu nie nie wenn ich den rechner neu kauf
oder wenn ich neue ssd systemplatte hab vielleicht sonst installiere ich nie
windows neu wozu auch das ist komplett auf der rate in windows neu installieren
braucht man eigentlich überhaupt nicht wie viel text im chat ist was geht denn
hier ab kann jeder flow sagt auch jetzt viel los im chat ist für das letzte
mal hatten wir fast fast das doppelte an zuschauen als wenn ich mit quasi gift
playern zu bettel viel konkurrieren mussten und da war auch nicht viel mehr
los im chat also wie gesagt überleg dir was du was du machen willst dann das
dann ergibt sich eigentlich die umgebung fast von selbst ok wo sind
stehen geblieben also der krampe funktioniert ungefähr wahrscheinlich
so ja seiner präsenz ist blabla gut und dann und dann brauchen wir jetzt unsere
unsere methode in der wir rennen dort und die nennen wir genauso wie bei
freese ich will einfach privat wollte denn da haben wir sogar nur damals sogar startrenner oder so genau so ja und die werfen wir in
einem extra task an und feiern forget und wurscht
das run und das schmeißen jetzt einfach des renner in die rein
fertig ach es geht ja nicht man muss ja so weil task
so das haben wir unser rennen angeworfen und nun müssen wir mal gucken ob wir es
schaffen den hintergrund von unserer windows form irgendwie rot oder so was
zu ändern einfach nur dass wir wissen dass der
direct x teil funktioniert weil wer weiß was ich damals da zusammen gebastelt
habe hier ob das überhaupt funktioniert hat am schluss
weiß er weiß er nicht ja so wenn das funktioniert dann
da bauen wir ein fps counter und da gucken wir mal wie wir bei einem
bei einem schwarzen oder roten hintergrund sagen hafte 15.000 fps haben
oder so weil er auch nichts macht im endeffekt
das soll die color brush und dann brauchen wir noch background color und
text kann text kann er braucht auf jeden fall
also das sollte man vielleicht meine schleifen machen was ja auch rennen
hat so geht das jetzt nee wir müssen noch swap chain
swappen glaube ich na so auf jane präsent müssen wir machen
macht so wenig damit soll mal gucken ob der bildschirm jetzt keine ahnung
schwarz wird ich kann mir das immer nicht merken null ist schwarz weil es
weiß na da funktioniert guckt wir rennen den bildschirm schwarz wahnsinn oder das
ist unglaublich
kann man hier eigentlich auch so was machen wie colors color kann man kann
man das eigentlich auch so verwenden oh das geht
nee das geht natürlich nicht das muss man hier mit so komischem direkt x gedöns
anlegen gibt es da nicht irgendwie was schöneres color kann man da eine color
vielleicht rein stecken oder so ich meine was soll das sein rock rock
color 4 muss anscheinend so sein was ein pink für eine was ein pink für ein rgb
ich gucke jetzt einfach mal nach 170 ja sowas
ach so mal liegt das jetzt da dran
was bilder was
nee was was was was ist ein pink was ist pink für eine schöne farbe ist doch ist
doch halbwegs pink
ach wo wisst ihr was wir machen jetzt gar nicht hintergrund wird schwarz
fertig aus und wir schreiben da jetzt ein text rein dann sehen wir auch ob es
funktioniert habe lambda ausdrücke nie ganz verstanden könntest du die
erläutern im prinzip ist ein lambda ausdruck nichts anderes wie wie eine
funktion also ganz billig gesagt wenn du eine wenn du eine wenn du ein argument
hast wo du quasi in c so ein pointer zu einer funktion machen würdest nimmst
halt lambda ausdruck für das ist das ist quasi sowas wie ein funktions pointer
bloß dass du es halt in line schreiben kannst also wenn du wenn man jetzt so
was hier sagt so das hier das hier zum beispiel wenn ihr guckt du kannst bei
allen sachen die eine action oder eine funk haben war der funk eine funk haben
wollen ach die farben gehen nur von null bis
da aus kein fuchs ist wieder am stand jeder der kennt sich glaube ich wirklich
mit da im links aus ich kann mich auch dran erinnern war das letzte mal am
start also wenn jetzt hier beispielsweise sie ist ihr task run will
eine action haben action bedeutet kein return wert fang bedeutet return wert
prinzipiell erstmal die ganze gibt es action und fang gibt es natürlich in der
generic variante wo du ihm dann sagen kannst was deine parameter sind und in
dem fall kannst du ihm sagen er möchte er möchte er will eine action das
bedeutet er will eine funktion haben ich kann aber zeigen dass das wirklich mit
einer funktion dann funktionieren er will eine funktion haben die keine
argumente bekommt und keine return wert hat so und anstatt jetzt das hier quasi
die funktion zu programmieren könntest du einfach sagen ok keine
argumente sondern das hier ist der eigentlich lambda ausdruck dieser feil
und das ist der body von einer funktion da kannst du sagen hier hallo twitch und
dann lässt das ding jetzt im hintergrund quasi diese funktion hier als action in
deinem task laufen das hier ist quasi der lambda ausdruck das
sind die argumente für die funktion also wenn du was hast was irgendwie keine
ahnung drei argumente kriegt weil es eine action ist mit keine ahnung und und
und dann hier sagt er mir jetzt halt das noch take drei argumente so und es ist
eine sache die sich wurscht gelesen hat diese mit mit der nächsten scharp
version verbessern wollen ist das erkennen von signaturen und so was ich
weiß nicht genau wie sie es machen wollen weil aus irgendwelchen gründen
funkt also die wollen dann dass man sowas hier machen kann weil aktuell ich
meine es ergibt überhaupt keinen sinn render ist eine funktion die ist wollte
und hat keine argumente die müsste eigentlich auf jeden fall zu action
passen aber er hat hier das problem dass er sagen kann ich weiß nicht ob du jetzt
action meinst oder function und das wollen sie nächste version irgendwie
verbessern dass er da nicht mehr von hand irgendwas machen muss kann man
eigentlich haben schon nie ausbild kann man nicht so was machen ja ok das
funktioniert wenn ich das nach action kaste ist gut dann klappt das ganze so
und jetzt und jetzt im prinzip ist das hier eigentlich nur ein zeiger zu meiner
render funktion ich weiß jetzt nicht wer es geschrieben war das war das soweit
verständlich was man damit macht wofür das natürlich machen wir mal einen
beispiel wofür das natürlich unglaublich praktisch ist einmal für
sachen wo du halt gar keine extra funktion machen willst weil es kurz so
knackig ist also hauptsächlich wo du keine extra funktion machen willst und
es halt kurz ja auch so kurz und knackig ist zum beispiel bei so einem task ist
es auch ganz nett wenn du quasi wenn wir noch öfter sehen wir brauchen wir
brauchen heute ein paar timer ich brauche ein paar timer und für die
funktion die der timer quasi beim tick benutzt ist kann man wunderbar als ein
lambda ausdruck schreiben weil das sind meistens nur zwei drei zeilen wenn
überhaupt ja den funktionsblock braucht man beim lambda ausdrücken gar nicht
wenn man einfach nur eine funktion verwendet also im prinzip so war so was
hier wir auch vollkommen ok aber man geht ja auch anscheinend so so wofür das
natürlich unglaublich praktisch ist ist wenn jetzt irgendwie eine liste aus ins
hast blub im box nein wir wollen uns keine melz angucken so und du willst
jetzt quasi sagen ok ich will meine liste mit ins komm wir sind auch noch
mal so nett und schreiben da was rein 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 was auch immer das
vollkommen wurscht so und du willst diese liste jetzt quasi durchsuchen und du
willst nur die elemente haben die größer als fünf sind dann würdest du einfach
schra einfach einfach sagen i ist der parameter für die funktion siehst du
auch hier wer nimmt eine function function in dem fall bedeutet es hat
return wird der return wird ist pool und int ist halt in dem fall eine zahl pro
durchlauf das ist in seite schleife intern sondern sagst du quasi für jede
das ist quasi eine vorschlag vor each life wenn du so willst für jede zahl in
dieser in dieser liste willst du willst du sagst du die bedingung i größer 5 so
und jetzt kriegst du als ergebnis von diesem lambda ausdruck also von dem hier
kriegst du jetzt quasi alle zahlen die größer als 15 also quasi das da willst
du mehr als eine zeile machen musste das ganze in wusste muss er dann block
draus machen und return davor schreiben weil da kann er sich das nicht selbst
ableiten und auch dich an semi kolons halten also im prinzip ist das eben war
die kürzere schreibweise davon ja also lambda sind unglaublich praktisch wenn
man sie da einsetzt wofür sie da sind für events sind die zum beispiel auch für
callbacks für callbacks sind die halt richtig gut ja also callback ist quasi
wenn ich jetzt mal um mich wird jetzt hier in den bild rendern und ich will
irgendwo jemand bescheid sagen dass ein neues bild da ist da würde ich sagen
action callback und derjenige der die render funktion auf ruft der steckt
hier quasi in lambda auf seiner seite rein und ich rufe den callback bei mir
einfach auf und sag ihm dann bescheid wenn man bild fertig ist dafür ist das
halt richtig geil dass das geht alles schon seit 50 jahren in z haben wir hier
wir haben doch hier ein paar z fans am start also wenn du dann was ist das was
ist das in z wo sternchen void oder sowas macht da kann sie auch alles
reinstecken wie du lustig bist wobei zumindest in z plus plus haben sie ja
mittlerweile schon ordentliche funktionszeiger und sowas wo man sich
nicht mal so sehr ins bein schießen kann mit und aber das ist hier ist das ist
in die scharf wirklich toll deswegen ist es auch eine meiner lieblingssprachen
schlechthin weil sich da macros auf wirklich gute sachen ausdenkt sie
scharf ist der vorreiter gewesen was er sing wait angeht ich will nicht
ausschließen dass es nicht schon vorher welche von den versuchen hätten aber
ohne scheiß die waren die ersten die das in der menschen sprache eingebaut haben
ja auch diese ganze link geschichte das ist schon toll hat man in z scharp
eigentlich auch eine algorithmo library klar also für mathe zeug für basic
mathe zeug hast du mathe aber ansonsten hast natürlich halt auch für für jedes
popelige ray quasi ja ich muss jetzt mal so hast du dann irgendwie baino
research und so eingebaut wenn ich jetzt wüsste wie der richtige typ ist also
fast also dass dort net framework ist ziemlich komplett dass dort net
framework ist ziemlich komplett callback wirstes event bauchgefühl
bauchgefühl manchmal ist es manchmal ist es mir lieber wenn ich quasi so quasi
auf klasse level event na sag mal so event ist umgedreht im gleich zu einem
callback ja bei dem eva also nicht wirklich unter der haufe geht geht geht
immer vom color thread aus aber ich glaube die meiste leute checken
überhaupt nicht was ich eigentlich vor mir gebe event definierter halt in der
klasse und deine klasse löst das event aus wohin wo wo sich quasi andere
transscriben können dass sie das auch haben wollen
den callback musst du ja explizit reinstecken und um ihn dann aufzurufen
das ist unter der haufe bei dem event im prinzip ganz genauso weil sowohl der
callback als auch das event und das darf man nie vergessen und vor allem
wenn gui zeug macht schießt man sich damit ganz schnell in fuß das wird immer
vom auslöser also das läuft immer im thread vom auslöser bedeutet wenn ich
jetzt hier irgendwie in meine render funktion wenn ich jetzt hier in den
callback reinstecke von außen von innen auf ruft und ich und ich löse diesen
callback aus der code was also die funktion dahinter die ist definiert bei
demjenigen der meine meine render methode auf ruft allerdings allerdings der
callback selbst der läuft in meinem render thread also ich rufe den auf der
code ist zwar woanders letztendlich was der callback dann unter was der wirklich
macht das weiß ich nicht aber der wird mit meinem thread aufgerufen ich rufe
den callback auf das heißt wenn jetzt irgendwie eine gui anwendung auf der
anderen seite dran ist und der quasi in seiner in seiner funktion die immer hier
als callback reingeschoben hat das klingt das klingt mega kappa prides
und ein bisschen haben wir hier ein oh nein da ist doch mein ist doch zu klein
dann rufe ich das mit meinem render thread auf was bedeutet wenn da eine
gui anwendung auf der anderen seite dran hängt wo keine ahnung irgendwas im
frontend geändert wird dann crash das ganze weil die gui anwendung sagt und
moment mal auf mich darf nur meinen mein gui thread zugreifen du darfst das gar
nicht ja ok hat man hat man das verstanden was ich jetzt von mir gegeben
habe war das irgendwie verständlich ja gut sehr schön da bin ich ja froh dass
das irgendwie sind ergibt ok ja und deswegen ist es wichtig dass man bei
gui anwendung immer schön invoked man muss man muss invoken gui anwendung
möchten invoked werden das ist gut habe ich kann haus verpasst oder so kann das
sein ich habe nämlich mein mein streaming zeug nicht auf wartet mal ich
bilde nämlich ein dass ich ganz leise im hintergrund den hosting sound gehört
habe ich muss das mal ja ja streamlabs gehe auf ich habe ach ich habe ich habe
echt ein haus verpasst ok moment leute seck ich wurde geradet von princess
catpaw dankeschön für den haus 27 leute ich weiß nicht ob ihr überhaupt ob man
überhaupt irgendwie auch nur anders weise nachvollziehen was ich hier
treiber aber wenn es euch gefällt ist alles gut ok also worauf wir eigentlich
ursprünglich raus wollten bevor ich jetzt hier in meinen wie callback excurs wie
wie callbacks und wie threat und hin und her aus geufert bin was wir eigentlich
machen wollten ist kurz gucken wo stehen geblieben sind genau wir schaffen schon
mit direkt x ein schwarzes fenster zu ändern das hat sich schon mal ganz toll
sondern eigentlich haben wir vor eine stunde zeit er dass das ich habe meine
bedenken ob das was wird wir wollen eigentlich mit ffm per gifs auslesen
wie lange machst du sie scharf schon lange irgendwie seit seit 2005 oder so
also ich habe ganz knapp nach version 11 angefangen
der schwarze fenster ist das beste schwarze wir können auch theoretisch ein
rotes fenster machen oder ein pinkes fenster oder sonst was aber wir wollen
jetzt ja da was rein malen so und zwar wir versuchen jetzt mal
man braucht nicht bild war bestimmt dieses komische mind blown gift da das da
so wir versuchen jetzt mal da dort dieses gift rein zu mal das klingt einfach ist
es aber nicht und ich weiß selbst noch nicht genau wie ich das machen wie ich
es machen werde so und wir wollten auch ein billig fps counter programmieren
dass wir dass wir uns fps anzeigen können
funktioniert das überhaupt was ich hier mache
funktioniert ich muss mal kurz überlegen funktioniert das überhaupt wenn
ich
oder macht er das jetzt überhaupt eigentlich sollte der hintergrund jetzt ja
weiß wer na gut passt weißer und weißer hinterkunden ist besser wenn was in wobei
nie unser fps counter wird weiß keiner text ok wir schreiben da jetzt mal was
rein ich schreibe da jetzt rein irgendwie
das kann schon mal abgucken
wie habe ich das das letzte mal gemacht hier beginn trot text ok also da
schreiben wir jetzt rein beginn trot dann sagen wir hier fps counter machen
wir mal weg und schreiben rein so was weiß ich danke für den host und text
format und dann schreibt ihr hier was rein und dann schreibt ihr hier was
und schreiben rein so was weiß ich danke für den host und text format brauchen
wir dann noch
wo habe ich das letzte mal hin kopiert ja so und jetzt gucken wir mal ob das
jetzt überhaupt rendert es wird wahrscheinlich hässlich wie die nacht
aussehen text ich mag direkt 2d nicht da muss die jeden schei selber machen
so ja textformat so und jetzt sollte eigentlich danke für den host in das
fenster schreiben was er macht es sieht zwar aus wie von 1995 aber er macht es
und es skaliert auch ich würde sagen
richtig ein massiver progas ist das ob es das die katze ich hätte vielleicht
mal für jedes bild mal eine größte festlegen soll anstatt dass ich das
naja was auch immer dafür dafür jetzt wenigstens hin und her zu schieben die
bilder
was ist da im chat los antialasen ist komplett auf rate das braucht man nicht
ok also erste hürde ist genommen wir sind in der lage danke für den host zu
rendern und das lassen wir allerdings nicht da drin wir machen jetzt wir machen
fps counter und gucken mal wie viele fps wir haben mit einem einfachen keine
ahnung 46 mal 480 fenster das einfach nur in den schwarzen hintergrund in der
endlosschleife gendert so das heißt wir sagen da kann ich mir was abgucken was
schon mal gemacht habe wir müssen wir müssen ja quasi nicht alles wir müssen
nicht alles neu erfinden so hier fps counter class fps das wird wahrscheinlich
der der räudigste fps counter überhaupt fps frames ich hoffe ich verstehe noch
was ich mir mal damals dabei gedacht habe ich tippe das jetzt einfach mal kurz
so ab und versuche zu verstehen was ich damals gemacht habe
das ist dass das ganze thread sicher ist das verstehe ich schon mal was ich da
getrieben habe also ich vermute mal dass hier einfach die frames hochgezählt
werden trotz sicher so dann habe ich gesagt ok jetzt weiß ich was ich mache
dann leg ich den timer an kann mir das einfach mal copy pasten habe das auf dem
zweiten bildschirm ja dann hat schön timer angelegt und dann hatten wir guck
jetzt an der stelle ist auch wieder falls er noch da ist der sich für lambda
geschichten interessiert hat
an der stelle ist kann man auch wunderbar wunderbar eine lambda verwenden
nämlich anstatt dass ich jetzt die methoden programmiert wurde das wo
drinne steht was bei einem tick passiert kann ich auch einfach sagen wir stecken
da eine quasi so eine inline funktion rein die allerdings natürlich event args
braucht sonst wird sie nicht funktionieren und dort machen wir das
hier so was sagt ihr zu meinem krassen fps counter
geiler beste fps counter alive so und jetzt können wir sagen war fps gleich
new fps passt ja zu mir das machen wir jetzt der heißt jetzt oder fps das ist
eine gute idee ok so und jetzt zählen wir einfach pro durchlauf pro durchlauf
zählen wir einfach die fps hoch und nachdem wir das hier halbwegs letztlicher
gemacht haben drinne also wir machen das hier immer atomic da kann nichts
passieren da hoffe ich das ist uralt ich habe das das das ist ursprünglich aus
irgendeinem linux gtk zeug wo ich das raus kopiert habe das hier mit dem wie
das wie das hier prinzipiell funktioniert plus halt den timer muss
halt für windows mal so so und nun gucken wir mal wie viel fps wir haben jetzt
einfach fps fps to string und jetzt gucken wir mal wie viel fps wir haben
all besser als kot besser als battlefield besser als fast alles also stimmt das
überhaupt was ich da gemacht habe das ist prinzipiell tatsächlich nicht so
viel ich hätte jetzt auch ein bisschen mehr erwartet aber ich kann damit leben
stimmt das überhaupt was ich hier mache vom zählen her also ich ich meine von
der logik kann es ja nicht so ich meine ich zähle pro durchlauf die fps und dann
einmal in der sekunde einmal in der sekunde aktuell ist setz ich die fp
setz ich die die die frames die gecounted werden auf null und schreibe das
was er quasi gezählt hat in fps das passt doch eigentlich oder es ergibt doch
eigentlich sinn
ich finde das klingt irgendwie relativ logisch dass das die fps pro sekunde
sind kannst aber nicht unter null fps gehen ich glaube das problem stellt sich
mir gerade nicht was hat er denn für objekte nicht initialisation can be
simplified gut sehr schön da lassen wir mal mit um den fps counter geht es ja
im endeffekt auch gar nicht ercountet sagenhafte 9000 also wir haben ungefähr
9000 fps fast schon 10.000 fps und wenn man das wahrscheinlich wenn man sich
damit ein bisschen besser auskennt ist es wahrscheinlich habe ich irgendwas
gemacht was wahrscheinlich einfach schon jetzt schon viel zu lang viel zu langsam
ist ok jetzt kommt natürlich der schwierige part und der part wo ich auch
so ein bisschen schiss vor hab weil ich keine ahnung habe ehrlich gesagt wie
das genau funktioniert ich meine ich habe zwar schon ein bisschen was mit ffm
pack gemacht und ich habe auch noch ein bisschen was gefunden hier bei mir mit
ffm pack aber da geht es nur teilweise um gifs was ich könnte man direkt ich
könnte mal direkt ja stimmt ich könnte mal direkt cashen ich käsche ich käsche
mal mein recht schreckt
und und wie viel performance boost bringt nix nicht wirklich sogar eher
langsamer sogar eher langsamer wird gekascht und brush nee brush kann ich
nicht cashen also ja kann ich aber der muss hier rein weil wenn ich später
resize dann kackt ab wenn ich den brush verwende den ich quasi mit alten
dingern erstellt habe die dann nicht mal nach nach dem nach dem resize nicht
mehr gültig sind dann kackt er ab deswegen muss der brush in die render
loop mit rein
so und zwar ffm pack und nicht dass ihr jetzt etwa denkt wir machen ffm pack so
billig mit wir rufen ffm pack als kommando zeilen tool auf und und holen
uns den output raus nein nein und das ist jetzt was für den für den für den
zebaro irgendeiner ist hier doch so da da da da ne ne der patrick ist glaube ich
oder c fern wir nehmen die raw dotnet ffm pack c bindings also sprich im
prinzip einfach die c bindings mit ein bisschen wrapper drumherum also da ist
nix mit das heißt das muss auch unsafe das muss unsafe sein sonst funktioniert
es nicht da gibt es so ein ding so ein projekt das macht nichts anderes wie
immer bei der neuen ffm pack version automatisiert quasi c sharp wrapper zu
generieren das heißt es ist immer immer aktuell
so bär
so also und ffm pack ist ist wir machen mal eine eigene klasse draus hier und
ich nenne es ich nenne zwar wieder um ich nenne es wenigstens counter und ich
violate die name conventions gott so dann schieben wir das in extra file sonst
wird sie ein bisschen voll und
und wir belassen so ist doch egal geht ja nicht darum lasst es schön
encode ist nur die video dateien dann in 264 ne wozu moment warum habe ich 143
zuschauer jetzt sind es nur noch 28 ist der hosting bot wieder am start
ich dachte die gucken alle bettel viel die code ist ne das ist ja ein gif also
wenn ich wenn ich das gif die code dann habe ich erst mal im speicher raw rgb
werte und encode will ich ja nicht weil ich will ja quasi ich will das gif die
code und dann habe ich rgb frame daten und die will ich quasi direkt hier ins
ins ja irgendwie hier als bitmap ins x reinhauen so also von der idee her was
man was wir zwar das wird das wird jetzt eklig das problem ich glaube wir
schaffen es heute auch nicht ganz dass da was sinnvolles bei rauskommt weil ich
habe ja bloß auch ungefähr eine stunde zeit aber morgens freitag wochenende
mit dann wird er wahrscheinlich jeden tag gesträmst also was wir auf jeden was
wir auf jeden fall brauchen ist
erst mal so ffm pack using ffm pack auto gen so das erste was wir machen muss
bei ffm pack ist
also das erste was wir ffm pack machen muss so rad ich mich doch dran erinnern
kann ist man muss irgendwie mal gucken wie ich das letzte mal hier gemacht habe
in diesem anderen projekt
musste man nicht irgendwie sagen in ffm pack oder sowas nee anscheinend nicht
anscheinend nicht ok wenn man das nicht wusste dann muss man nicht also was wir
auf jeden fall brauchen oder was wir machen muss also das ding hier ist auf
jeden fall schon mal an safe es geht nicht anders muss unsafe sein weil wir
raw c bindings verwenden ohne irgendwas anzelt so und weil das anzelt ist
müssten wir hier auch irgendwo unter bild sagen dass wir anzelt erlauben
sonst funktioniert nicht und wie gesagt das ist bloß ein testprojekt einfach um
zu gucken wie man das gift ordentlich eingelesen kriegen alles muss anzelt
sein ja ach ja und übrigens nachdem das jetzt c bindings sind müssen wir auch
selbst freen und allokaten und so geschiss machen wo ich ja schon wahnsinnig
scharf drauf bin wahrscheinlich werden wir jetzt eben memory leaks des todes
erst mal verursachen weil ich die helfe nicht freigebe aber solange gibt's
gibt's ausliest ist alles gut also wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe was ich hier
schon mal vorbereitet habe dann wir haben so viele katzen emotes im chat
muss mal katz fps zu der gelegen hat mal anzeigen
ups ja die katze war schon echt niedlich ja das ist das ist das erste mal
wo ich sie glaube ich sie ganz neu hatte da hat sie sich da unten reingelegt
wollte erst mal nichts von mir wissen und hier hier hat sie schon weniger
probleme mit
hat es damit überhaupt nichts zu tun ist mir gerade wieder eingefallen weil
katz fps weilt ja leider nicht mehr unter uns
ja okay weiter im text
ach so guck mal wie viel ram das ding jetzt hier braucht
guck mal ich habe ich habe ich schon memory leaks ich habe schon memory leaks
ich habe noch nicht angefangen richtig und ich habe schon memory leaks wahnsinn
ich weiß warum ich weiß warum ich memory leaks habe
passt mal auf brusch des pose
oder auch nicht
oder doch alles braucht es geht am anfang bloß ein bisschen okay das war es
also ich habe kein memory leak mehr ich meine ich kann ja auch nicht viel
memory leaks haben ich mache ja nix im endeffekt
ich meine was soll hier liegen aus ich mache nix noch nicht okay weiter im text
also wenn ich wenn ich mir das jetzt richtig ansatz brauchen wir als erstes
einen pointer zu einem av codec kontext fragt mich jetzt nicht mehr genau warum
aber ich vermute mal dass den code den ich da hier in dem anderen projekt wo ich
abgucke fabriziert habe dass der funktioniert wenn ich aber gelitten so als
nächstes brauchen wir ein format codec ein format kontext das ist das zeugs
heißt halt so weil ffm pack das so nimmt es und so nennt also wenn ich das
richtig erinnert habe das hier ist quasi die klasse mit der man die code also wo
man dann den jeweiligen die kodereien lädt und das hier halt wo irgendwie
infos zum format irgendwie drinne sind oder so
der thera fox der gc bringt in dem fall gar nichts das ist ja unmanaged zeugs
hier sowohl direkt x als auch als auch ffm pack du musst selbst fliehen wenn
du nicht selbst fließt und in dem fall halt die pausen was unter der haube
wahrscheinlich wir können das dekort nicht angucken wahrscheinlich das
gleiche macht dann ist weg
ok so dann habe ich mir aufgeschrieben wir brauchen hier noch einen stream index
was bei gif eventuell ein bisschen overkill ist ich meine bei gif gibt es
genau ein stream können wir eigentlich gleich sagen null dann brauchen wir ein
av frame av frame frame wie alle allocaten den kramppel gleich noch alles dann aber
wir brauchen ein av packet und ansonsten sieht der decoding code der danach kommt
sieht relativ straight forward aus also das könnte sogar wenn wir glück haben
einfach funktionieren so und jetzt müssen wir den ganzen krempel noch
initialisieren das bedeutet wir müssen jetzt mal ffm pack punkt av format oh nee
ich hoffe das ist mit einer neuere ich hoffe nicht dass ich das mit alten
versionen erstellt habe die es jetzt nicht mehr gibt also wo es die funktionen
nicht mehr gibt av format allocate kontext genau das brauchen wir jetzt und
das kommt jetzt da rein wo ist das problem da steht da so drinnen dass ich
das so machen muss
ah moment falsch der da muss sein ok wir gucken wir gucken jetzt mal ob der
krempel jetzt bis jetzt überhaupt schon mal läuft
nein es ist es ist gecrasht es ist gecrasht also
es ist es ist gecrasht weil wenn es nicht gecrasht wer würde das jetzt hier
ändern ach ok ich weiß ich weiß woran es liegt das ist eigentlich richtig
bescheuert ich habe die ffm pack library ist doch gar nicht die muss ich erst mal
downloaden lull wenn das bild wenn ich die ffm ach ja und man braucht 32 spit
weil ansonsten spackt rum ich weiß auch nicht genau warum aber ich nehme
32 das weiß ich doch da habe ich letztes mal ewig gebraucht ffm pack in mit
64 spitzen laufen zu kriegen habe ich einfach 32 glaube es hat funktioniert
shared dass die libraries dabei sind download ja ich meine das kann ja
ohne libraries nicht funktionieren ich denke mal wenn ich hier irgendwie den
try catch drumherum mach
da wird er mir auch sagen dass er die libraries nicht laden kann ja guck
unable to load na geil ok aber das passt das können wir ja relativ einfach
umgehen wir werfen die libraries jetzt einfach da rein die wir da gelaudet
haben zack ganz ffm pack binaries oder ist das geschiss und nun muss ich wie
ging das jetzt muss ich wenn aus irgendwie sagen dass die libraries da
sind oder reicht es wenn ich die rein kopiere ne wahrscheinlich nicht da
gucken wir uns mal github gucken wir uns mal an die hatten nämlich ein example
projekt wie die das da machen register ffm binary helfer bei register register
ffm pack binaries platform windows path kombine
wisst ihr was ist dir was wir wollen ja zu porte kommen wir kopieren uns das
jetzt einfach und dann geht es einfach wahrscheinlich hoffentlich
und dann ist dann wird es hier mal in nicht in der form sondern hier im form
starten also ffm pack binaries helfer register ffm pack binaries und
wahrscheinlich heißt der ordner jetzt nicht richtig wow ok ganz krempel
importieren import was ist was das problem import soll jetzt aber
funktioniert nicht mein ordner heißt bestimmt falsch ffm pack ok groß muss ffm
pack klein soll das heißen bin und dann sucht da x86 ok x86
wobei eigentlich doch egal oder wir machen einfach nur bin machen einfach
nur bin schon funktioniert ffm pack binaries found
ob doch mal schön alles copy pasted ok jetzt kann man mit der eigentlichen
geschichte weitermachen ok kann man den try catch block wieder weg machen ok
also format kontext ffm context so als nächstes müssen wir als nächstes
müssen wir das hier machen
moment
als nächstes müssen wir das hier machen wir müssen den kram öffnen und zwar
hier müssen wir jetzt unser gif feil öffnen was in dem fall fs
kommen wir nehmen wir nehmen mal den wir nehmen mal den vogel der ist besser
der ist kleiner ist gif öffnen p-format kontext
warum also ich habe hier was in meinem in meinem coach drinne stehen der
ziemlich sinnlos aussieht
so was in der richtung steht da drinnen aber warum
warum steht das da drinnen was genau soll ffm pack in den program machen
gifs gif einlesen und dann in da mit x raus hauen
so steht das bei mir in dem anderen in meinem anderen programm drinne aber
das das funktioniert nicht moment es ist ja auch falsch
was erwartet der denn hier av format kontext format kontext doch gut
kann ich nicht einfach den scheiß selbst reinschieben moment moment das ist
richtig ich habe bloß irgendein anderes argument vergessen kann das sein
ja ich habe noch die argumente vergessen ich hätte mal ein bisschen nach links
rollen sollen so ok jetzt funktioniert ich habe keine ahnung warum ich das hier
gemacht habe ich ich ich lasse es jetzt aber mal so weil ich weiß es hat mal
funktioniert so als nächstes habe ich mir hol ich mir den stream aus dem gif
raus wobei ich ok dann brauchen wir sowas hier so was brauchen wir dann
auf aus stream auch immer gleich null gehe weg auf fort auf aus stream soll
da muss ich mir den stream rausholen und zwar sage ich da format kontext streams
hoffentlich funktioniert der krempel format kontext streams null
steams ja
null
ach so ich muss jetzt ich muss jetzt natürlich was zuweisen und zwar stream
was meinst du matt was warum wir das machen das kann ich dir zeigen ich bastel
hier in dem tool was quasi overlays und sounds und sowas anzeigen kann man kann
damit auch bilder verschieben also den kann man da anzeigen lassen den kann man
da anzeigen lassen und du kannst ja auch mal ein bisschen mehr anzeigen lassen
man kann damit auch bilder verschieben also den kann man da anzeigen lassen und
du siehst ja dass es aktuell macht es einfach mit einer transparenten wpf form
dass die bilder hinterher legen und das große gifs ewig zum laden brauchen weil
diese wpf gif library anscheinend relativ lahm ist deswegen will ich mal
gucken ob wir das selbst schneller hinkriegen
guck ich klicke jetzt mal jetzt ist erst da größere gifs mal gucken ob wir das
selbst irgendwie besser hinkriegen so
danach habe ich sowas hier drinne stehen bei mir codec id codec id habe ich nicht
kopiert wo wo ist codec id codec id ist codec context hier sind wir jetzt müssen
auch diese komischen pointer geschichten ihr verwenden codec
all die soll mal gucken ob der ganze temple jetzt noch läuft also ist das
problem oh habe ich das nicht in initialized
nee habe ich nicht muss ich noch machen codec context
ich finde mich in meinem anderen source gott nicht wirklich zurück zu recht
gerade was ich da getrieben habe achte stream codec brauche ich codec context
und das ist stream codec so rum ok ja ja ja so läuft der krempel noch er läuft
noch er läuft noch ok jetzt haben wir ab jetzt ist ab jetzt ist der code
eigentlich relativ einfach jetzt haben wir unseren decoder nennen wir ihn auch
mal genau so ab jetzt haben wir unseren unseren decoder mit dem wir gift frames
decoden können so und dann muss man eigentlich einfach nur ok jetzt muss man
noch jetzt muss man auch das packet das packet muss man noch noch ram für
reservieren und dann muss man für den frame noch ram reservieren weil halt c
und sowas da muss man sowas halt machen eigentlich müssen wir das übrigens auch
alles freen aber das wir gucken einfach mal wir produzieren heute einfach ein
paar memory leaks so und nun kann ich einfach schon wenn ich das richtig sehe
hier die gif gifs die kauten ich backen wir machen das jetzt mal so ich mache
jetzt einmal eine schleife wo ich alle gifs alle alle bilder vom gif die kode
oder das erste bild vom gif ich decode das erste bild vom gif und dann schreiben
wir das erste bild vom gif mal irgendwie hier in immer die x-zeuge rein so und
dazu muss ich nämlich sagen read frame read frame und zwar für den format
kontext will ich ein was packet ok so und jetzt kriege ich jetzt kriege ich
hier quasi die bild daten von einem gif frame wenn ich das richtig sehe
so jetzt kann ich noch genau jetzt kann jetzt kann ich noch die kauten da sage
ich das hier ok das ergibt auch halbwegs den dann sage ich das hier ich schicke
jetzt das ist jetzt der kode konn kontext also sprich das ding was die kodet und
da schieb ich jetzt das packet rein wo die daten zum die kauten drin stehen und
danach sage ich einfach nur sie frame also quasi nachdem die also quasi
die kode nachdem du jetzt die kode tast nachdem du jetzt die kode tast gibt mir
den frame ohne und gibt mir den frame und jetzt sollte ich eigentlich in frame
die rgb daten drinne stehen haben für mein aktuelles gif bild jetzt ist
natürlich die preisweite meinte das funktioniert also wenn es funktioniert
müssten wir jetzt gleich irgendwie nen ja gut wie zeige ich das jetzt überhaupt
an wie zeige ich das jetzt überhaupt an ich muss jetzt ja irgendwie also mal
angenommen ich habe jetzt wofür ist die variable kode da steht drinne wahrscheinlich
stehen da informationen drinne was ist was es ist also sprich dass es ein gif
die kode ist und zeugs
ich weiß auch nicht mehr so genau was ich da gemacht habe aber das muss so
sein dass es funktioniert das weiß ich noch geht oder svn na ja aber geht
geht meilenweit vorne rgb oder rgb oder a rgb oder bg ra oder abg er ich glaube
bg ra hat es irgendeiner gecheckt können wir mal überprüfen gucken wir uns das
doch mal an frame format was ist was ist denn was ist denn für ein image format
ist das muss man glaube ich irgendwie noch carsten av pixel format gucken wir
uns mal an was ist für einen das müsste gb das müsste bg ra sein
beim gif
pixel format nan vielleicht kann ich das aber auch daraus nicht auslesen
pixel format nan ist jetzt okay gucken wir mal hier was der kodak meint was es
ist nan
ich glaube da habe ich irgendwas verkehrt gemacht jetzt das format sollte nicht nan
sein ich glaube nicht dass das so gedacht ist
ich habe ja auch ich habe ja was ich habe das wichtigste vergessen
mega null was ich vergessen habe hier ganz offensichtlich ich muss ja erst mal
auslesen was es eigentlich für ein format ist das habe ich ja noch gar
nicht gemacht das habe ich übersehen da steht nämlich gar nix drin
moment warum null warum null vielleicht geht es jetzt ja bg ra sage ich doch bg
ra ist es gut jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich hier meinen frame wie kriege ich
denn jetzt den frame da rein ich weil wir können so was sagen wie hier painter
paint ne tror bitmap und übrigens wie das der zufall so will haben wir unser
direct x content auch mit bg ra als pixel format nennt man das eigentlich
richtig als als farbformat nee keine ahnung als format haben wir auch bg ra
das heißt das stimmt überein das heißt es müsste prinzipiell funktionieren
jetzt ist bloß die frage
wie können wir nun bitmap malen ich weil wir haben ja wirklich wir haben alle
daten da und zwar wenn ich mal muss ich jetzt mal nachgucken wie ich hier euch
glaube ich wäre krank leute wenn ich das hier nämlich richtig sehe in meinem
beispiel code den ich eben vor jahren schon mal gebastelt habe wenn ich das
da richtig sehe dann kann ich nämlich mit
mit frame mit frame data null auf die pixel zugreifen von von meinem bitmap
jetzt ist nur die frage wie kriege ich die die wie kriege ich die also ich
kopiere mir einfach mal warte mal moment moment data null ist der erste pixel ja
also das ist so es gibt data null bis data frag mich nicht data ich sag mal
20 aber man darf jetzt nicht den fehler machen weil das ist ffmpeg logik frag
mich nicht wer sich das ausgedacht hat also man darf sich nicht denken dass
data null der erste pixel ist und data 2 der zweite pixel also es ist das hier
ist das ist was ganz abgedrehtes da steht da geht jetzt wahrscheinlich allen c
programmieren ein ab das hier ist dann wiederum den zeiger auf den bald also
data ist quasi in den ist quasi in den array auf point an zu point an zu
erase also ein ein meter pointer quasi also ein point reception wenn man so
will ein array mit point an zu weiteren point an die zu erase point an ist data
so und data null ist der erste pointer der zu einem byte array pointed man
sieht ja auch hier bei pointer zu weit das ist das ist das erste bei vom array
wenn man weiß dass es in der race muss man raten weiter bei pointer check
wahrscheinlich keiner jetzt aber ich weiß das noch weil ich damit ein bisschen
mit rum gebastelt habe und so und data null sind die bildtaten data eins ist
dann so was wie keine ahnung könnte audio daten sein data zwei ist dann so
was wie untertitel oder so wisst ihr also sprich und data null sind immer die rgb
bild daten deckt sich auch mit dem was ich hier in meinem anderen programm
da gebastelt haben so und jetzt ist natürlich die große frage wie paint ich
ein bitmap wie paint ich ein bitmap mit direkt 2d aus pixel
ja wie mache ich das
also ich war ein pixel kann ich hier ganz offensichtlich nicht reinschieben
höhere mal breite mal 4 size in bytes wahrscheinlich ja weil halt 4 bytes pro
pixel ok ich leg doch hier oben schon irgendwo mal bitmap an wo ich am ende
rein mal wie mache ich das denn new bitmap für painter und surface so für
painter ist ja prinzipiell ok aber für für mein backbuffer will ich ich will
es ja nicht verbinden ich will im prinzip ein bitmap wo ich einfach zeugs
reinschreiben kann also irgendwie keine ahnung
und nennen was nennen was mal anders nennen was mal traubig was so und da
schieben es rein den painter den brauche auf jeden fall weil damit malen
war und dann sagen wir hallo wo ist das problem
das geht mir halt bei den microsoft geschichten teilweise auf den sack dass
die die gleichen klassen haben überall in allen möglichen namespaces wir wollen
direkt 2d 1 bitmap folgen haben painter
da war man das size das size von
das sei moment wie groß soll unser bitmap sein ich würde ja sagen frame
fremd breite mal fremd höhe so breit soll unser bitmap sein
ah bitmap properties ok jetzt habe ich ein bitmap wie das geht mir ein bisschen auf
den sack dass ich jetzt hier quasi doppelt allocate muss weil wir sind ja
performance orientiert hier gerade ich mache jetzt ein leeres bitmap um da
wiederum quasi mein bitmap rein zu kopieren obwohl ich doch eigentlich
schon ein bitmap habe auf der anderen seite stimmt das gar nicht weil das hier
ist auf der grafikkarte das hier ist auf der grafikkarte mein mein mein frame
also mein meine meine mein frame ist im ram das heißt ich komme eh nicht drum
herum den kram auf die grafikkarte zu kopieren
ok da müssen wir jetzt mal google bemühen copy bites how create managed
da bitmap form was das für eine seite wie japanisch oder so a bitmap manipulation
copy bites from bitmap to byte array ok da soll die clone bitmap okay wir
gucken mal wir tasten dran vor was das alles gibt
how to create copy form memory copy form memory das klingt auch prinzipiell nicht
schlecht
kann ich warum warum kann ich jetzt nicht einfach beids rein stecken in den
constructor und gut ist warum warum ist das so kompliziert data pointer ha ha
moment leute
da habe ich doch gerade was gesehen data pointer pointer to memory location auf
bitmap auf image data das ist doch genau das was verbrauchen big brain na einfach
mal zugucken was ist was ist für funktionen aufgrund das kann ich einfach
einen pointer sein ein das muss ein ein schab die x data pointer sein wie
auch immer man den kack verwendet also sei es data pointer in pitch
wahrscheinlich was war pitch bei bitmaps noch mal war das wie viel war das wie
viel wie viel wie viel bei jetzt eine zeile hat war das das
bei skandale in richtung ja ja genau jaja im prinzip schon
data pointer ok wie verwendet man das denn also also leute wir haben jetzt
ungefähr 20 minuten zeit mal gucken ob wir dem scheiß irgendwie noch ein bild
entlocken können deswegen soll ich falls sie irgendwie
ein bisschen konfus konfus sein soll ich weiß selbst nicht weiß ich mal data
pointer 0 ne new dieser neuen korsar tastatur ne ich kann nicht richtig tippen
in pointer in size void pointer oder da geht im c programmierer das herz auf
oder da geht einer ab
ok dann schieben wir mal am pointer rein würde ich sagen sei es ich glaube ich
glaube wir können das zu einem in pointa carsten ist schon ja wie groß ist die
size quasi breite mal höhe mal vier also frame breite mal frame das wird nie
was das wird im leben nix mal vier memory so
ok wo ist der data pointer wieser wieser diese so
so
moment jetzt jetzt noch mal
doch er weiß sie eigentlich aber ich muss sie trotzdem noch mal angeben weil
weil man weiß es nicht und das soll jetzt funktionieren
das hätte mich auch sehr gewundert wenn es funktioniert wie kriege ich
eigentlich gescheit aus dem thread exception raus ohne da im try catch
block kommt try try catch block drumherum also im prinzip glaube ich ja
dass das hier irgendwas der abgang macht den rest haben wir schon ausprobiert
da funktioniert ja stimmt du hast recht pitch ist nur eine zeile es ist ich
hätte ich hätte schon wieder voll verkackt jetzt dass deswegen ist er
wahrscheinlich abgekackt ist wahrscheinlich mit ex exes things memory
jaja steht steht ja sogar dafür so deppen wir mich gucken wir hier es ist
die breite mal die anzahl der pixel aus ist gar nicht mal prü es ist es ist nur
so haben wir das mal an die stelle wo ich aufgehört habe im wir werden leute
wir werfen mit 260 fps die sekunde exceptions sind ein sehr sehr nice
exceptions rower unsupportet pixelformat the pixel the bitmap pixelformat ist
unsupportet progas
ich habe eine idee und zwar man konnte hier doch irgendwie in pixelformat
angeben ja guckt hier bitmap properties das brauchen wir bestimmt new bitmap
properties und was braucht das ding als arg als args ein pixelformat new pixel
format format moment wie wie hat sich das noch mal geschrieben was wir hier
haben b8 das ist wieder machen wir mal zeit und
pro rein was ist das problem a alpha mode
wat was willst du pre multi unknown also sprich wie die transparents wie das
wieder transparent bei verwendet werden soll oder was
doch doch auskennen folks doch doch weg wie wir können alle bitmaps einmal im
voraus kandidieren mir geht es aktuell eher darum wie render ich überhaupt
mit map ich habe jetzt ja ich habe jetzt ja hier quasi den ersten frame die
code und ich versuche jetzt den ersten frame zu rennern
das mit 90 fps nicht ich werde erstmal ein sleep dazwischen machen um zu gucken
ob es prinzipiell funktioniert danach werde ich einfach dass danach kommt das
ehe hier raus danach werde ich so machen denke ich dass ich das ffm pack in den
eigenen thread packen und es dann dort ein bisschen vorsicht ins lieben lasse
und es einfach dann event wirft oder so wenn frame da ist oder irgendwas weil
ich kann ja mit ffm pack ausrechnen wie viel fremds pro sekunde ich habe das
sehe ich ja das steht ja einen kodak information drin
ja was nämlich jetzt ich nehme das erste ich habe keine ahnung
ja bei alpha value ist pre multiplied klar was war sonst kein ding
pre multiplied wo alter was ist denn jetzt schon wieder
kennel kam er zu bitmap properties ok das heißt wir brauchen so was
rekt so geht es jetzt ich habe mit klammer vergessen ok
boah keine exception mehr keine exception mehr oh aber wir haben
memory leaks auf dumm wenn ich das jetzt eine minute laufen lasse ich muss ich
muss wahrscheinlich einfach nur disposen das bitmap ist wieder gut aber scheiß
drauf auch ein anderes postes bitmap also auch ein memory geliegtes bitmap kann
ich zum anzeigen verwenden ok ich mache mal die try catch gedöns wieder
weg ok ich würde fast sagen jetzt kommt der moment der wahrheit oder painter
tror bitmap bitmap toller namen painter tror bitmap und als input tror bitmap
opacity 1 1 ist nicht transparent bitmap interpolation options
news neighbor das schnellste jetzt kommt der moment der wahrheit meint ihr wir
sehen ich jetzt müssen wir mal meint ihr wir sehen jetzt was vom rare parrot
oder nicht also wir müssten jetzt den ersten frame vom rare parrot sehen
ihr habt da aber viel vertrauen drin also ich muss mich turbo denn anschließen
ich habe meine wirklich großen zweifel ob das funktioniert ich glaube es kackt
ab zwischendurch geht nicht geht nicht es wäre auch zu einfach gewesen oder das
einfach funktioniert hätte
tja
bitmap mal nach dem text malen gute idee
aber es kackt schon mal nicht ab moment ich muss mal kurz gucken steht in nummer
zu gucken es müsste doch jetzt hier in dem frame was drinnen sein
wir machen es mal anders ich nehme an den code von meinem ursprünglichen
von dem wie ich hier bei mir in dem anderen programm drinne stehen hab
das heißt jetzt habe ich halt den letzten frame dann auch gut
ich hätte gerne irgendwie noch zumindest mal ein
bilder sache entlockt bevor ich los mache man müsste halt mal wissen ob
überhaupt in dem frame was drinnen ist ich habe was vergessen
moment mal wartet mal ich habe was vergessen moment das glaube das ffm pack geht nicht
wartet mal leute guck mal ich habe was vergessen ich glaube der coder konnte gar nicht decoden
ah scheiße
habe ich noch irgendwas vergessen so wir gucken mal ob er den krempel überhaupt
als gif erkennt ich copy paste mir das jetzt mal von meinem anderen zeug
erkennt er das überhaupt als gif ja er erkennt als gif
also ich habe ich hier irgendwie einen logik fail drinnen
ok wir geben uns mal die frame höhe und breite aus
null moment null
da stimmt doch was nicht null ist auf jeden fall
also null finde ich komisch da stimmt irgendwas nicht
null leute ich glaube das also ich glaube das ist nicht richtig decoded hier was ich
mache ich glaube das prinzipiell alles funktionieren würde aber in dem frame nichts drinnen steht
ich möchte auch ein zweifel dass das gif null breit ist
ich habe noch was was wir mal gucken können wir können gucken wie hoch die frame rate
ist ah das ist ja immer kompliziert 25 ok das ist prinzipiell nicht der decoded allerdings
den frame nicht warum die kauder den frame nicht
guck mal leute der decoded nicht der break direkt ja der decoded nicht warum decoded der
decoded nicht wir haben irgendwas nicht allocated sag ich euch wir haben irgendwas vergessen
wir allocate den frame das mache ich hier in meinem anderen programm auch danach suche
ich für pixelformat framesize codec namen habe ich überhaupt den richtigen kommt ffmpeg
vielleicht mit mit leerzeichen ne ne muss er ja muss er ja muss es ja lesen können er
weiß auch dass 25 fps sind das hätte auch gemeckert wenn das nicht funktioniert ach
moment moment ja das delta der hat recht richtig ob auch richtig dumm ok und jetzt jetzt gucken
wir uns mal an frame breite da ist was da ist was oh was jetzt meine maus geht nicht
ich glaube ich glaube wir liegen zu liegen zu viel memory
aber ey ohne scheiß leute eins kann ich sagen bei audio video zeug wenn man schon mal irgendwas
anderes mit einem gewissen muster rauskriegt dann macht man es prinzipiell richtig man
hat nur an manchen stellen das falsche drinne stehen wenn es komplett schwarz ist komplett
weiß ist oder random pixel sind dann ist was falsch hier ist jetzt prinzipiell der ablauf
ok also was wenn er sich aus diesem fehler schon mal wissen ist das bitmap drawn funktioniert
allerdings trotter nicht das richtige ich wette mit euch das hier ist falsch ich ich
wette mit euch das hier ist falsch oder oder das hier ist falsch wahrscheinlich ist das
hier falsch weil er schreibt er hier extra noch es ist equal zu pixel mal number pro
bytes pro breite number pro bytes plus memory padding ich habe keine ahnung ob das ding
nicht irgendwie quasi noch ein bisschen das muster noch mal zeigen das ist das ist eindeutig
der papa geil das ist eindeutig der papa geil und und was wir auch dran sehen das das
farb schema also das das farb also das farbformat das ist das ist richtig ich glaube das hier
stimmt nicht und ich habe ja pitch ist falsch denke ich auch ich denke das liegt hier dran
also hier dran und hier dran weil die schreiben ja auch es ist explicit memory padding deswegen
wir gucken mal ich habe nämlich die idee ich bilde mir nämlich ein man kann aus dem frame
konnte man doch sagen irgendwas mit line line size konnte man nämlich sagen im frame line
size 0 und line size ist ja size bytes each picture line poggers poggers oh fuck oh ne
es kackt wieder ab das shit ist on fire das kackt übelst ab ich allocate zu viel zeug
im hintergrund
und nicht zu vergessen ok ok leute es ist ein 22 11
ja das machen wir jetzt einmal wir zeugen das einmal vor der schleife später können
wir das nicht mehr machen später müssen wir das ja pro pro durchgang irgendwie kackt
schon mal nicht mehr richtig ab aber es trott auch keine warum trott ist keine fps mehr
achso weil ich das bitmap drüber trotter achso das bild ist weiß und die fps denn auch
weiß ok das ist nicht die allerschlauste idee gewesen weil wir die fps mal schwarz
guck mal wir trauen jetzt ein einzelne 1 bild mit genauso viel fps wie vorher ungefähr
ne wir machen das morgen geht schon mal gut los ja progas glaube ich werde eh krank jetzt
ohne scheiß mit rülster haltschraue
wartet mal 1 1 war jetzt noch schnell auskommentieren weg damit her damit her damit das will ich
jetzt noch mal kurz ausprobieren ganz quick and dirty zack zack das wieder in die schleife
rein aber irgendwie aber hin ist eigentlich vollkommen wurscht achso übrigens der auskenn
fuchs hat recht das bitmap müsste ich muss ich eigentlich nicht jedes mal neu anlegen
komplett sondern einfach immer nur neu reinschreiben wie dem auch sei wir disposen das hier unten
mal
guck mal pass mal auf wir kriegen jetzt noch eine animation hin das geht schnell 100 millisekunden
einem
BÄM! Habt ihrs gesehen? Habt ihrs gesehen?
Koggers!
Ich bin jetzt wirklich zufrieden.
Jetzt nur noch ne Schleife.
Das nächste Mal machen wir das ganz einfach.
Wir speichern uns die Frames einfach und machen dann ne Loop draus.
Also das ist dann...
Gut, Rest machen wir morgen Leute.
Ähm...
Ich muss jetzt pennen.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns morgen.
Machts gut!
CU!
Hatt ich nicht irgendwie so ein guter Nachtbild?
Hatt ich mal irgendwie so ein guter Nachtbild?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Machts gut! Bis dann, CU!
Hatt ich mal irgendwie so ein guter Nachtbild?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Machts gut! Bis dann, CU!
Hatt ich mal irgendwie so ein guter Nachtbild?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Machts gut! Bis dann!